tatsächlich teleshopping ist natürlich
auch sehr bequem
das heißt ich sitze zu hause und bekomme
auch unter anderem von ihnen wirklich
produkte angeboten ist das nicht
vielleicht auch so ein bisschen zuviel
verführung dass sich irgend etwas
bestelle was ich vielleicht entweder gar
nicht brauche oder tatsächlich auch gar
nicht bezahlen kann
das ist natürlich wie jeden individuell
jeder sollte wissen was kann ich mir
leisten was kann ich mir nicht leisten
ich glaube wie er dass der verkauf auf
den verschiedenen plattformen und das
verkaufen von produkten egal ob platz in
einer automechaniker dienst anbieten
heutzutage gibt es wichtig in bewegtbild
bearbeiten wir sehen es auf bereichen e
commerce plattformen und das
teleshopping das urgestein des
bewegtbild es verkaufen er überleben
aber kunden ein ganz anderes sage ich
mal auch prinzip jeder als nur ein bild
eines produktes und diese
dienstleistungen dass der hunde wirklich
das produkt noch mal anders wahrnehmen
kann
das ist ein großer großer vorteil was
ist gegen doping vorgelebt hat und
vorreiter wird in das teleshopping auch
zu den gewinnern der korona krise also
das hätte das eine interessante frage
weil ich hätte auch genau das gegenteil
sein können beim teleshopping haben wir
sehr sehr schnell um gedacht diese idee
die ich hatte wo ich gesagt habe ich
stelle mein badezimmer zur verfügung
weil wenn wir einen shutdown gehabt
hätten hätte es bedeutet wir können
nicht senden wir sind ja dort in
fernsehstudios wo wir live senden und
der kunde auch das große den großen
vorteil hat dass die sendung live sind
man kann fragen stellen zu den produkten
was eine da interessiert und ich glaube
wenn wir das nicht getan hätten und
nicht innovative kreative neue
verkaufskonzepte gebracht hätten
sind wir da haarscharf
der katastrophe vorbeigeschlittert und
haben das ganze dann in einen gewinner
modus gebracht natürlich sind die
umsätze sehr gestiegen in der zeit